so let's define what the broke his man
is so think about what broke to me it's
broke to me is you have a lot of debt
you can't make the payments you're
behind the eight ball you're stressed
out every decision you're making you're
making it from place of panic right I'm
about to introduce to you the brokest
man in the world and they're making
desperate decisions and when a man of
the household keeps making desperate
decisions guess who gets the biggest
price that they have to pay the kids of
that father that's making all these bad
decisions financially right so before I
introduce this man to you to realize who
this person this irresponsible person is
if I give you value this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
let's get right into it America's in
debt 31.5 trillion dollars Uncle Sam is
the brokest man in the world but here's
a kicker do you know what is the biggest
interest payment we ever paid in the
history of America Q4 of
2022 it was the first time ever where
our interest payment was 213 billion
dollars the quarter prior to that was
the first time ever we paid above 180.
four quarters in a row was the biggest
interest payment we've ever paid in the
history of America but here's a problem
with that in 2020 the interest we were
paying on our 29 trillion was 0.5
percent in 2021 was 0.1 percent in 2022
there was around 1.9 percent in 2023
we're going to be between four and a
half to six percent that we have to pay
on our debt this will be the first year
in the history of America where America
is going to be paying trillion dollars
in interest on our loan on our debt of
thirty one and a half trillion dollars
here's a chart to look at okay our debt
to GDP ratio is the highest ever at 124
America has never been here before by
the way even after World War II if you
go to 1942 to around 1988 our debt
national debt was around four and a half
trillion dollars to around six trillion
dollars for 46 years
for 46 years we kept it around the four
and a half to six trillion dollars for
46 years and then all of a sudden
America got into debt spent spent spent
spent spent spent spent spent and now
these interest payments are going to go
so you know we just did the whole
inflation reduction area act that we
paid 1.7 trillion dollars oh my God
that's so much money don't be surprised
if 12 months from now our interest is
1.5 trillion dollars in 2023 the way
they're raising rates number one country
in the world with national debt is U.S
for 31.5 trillion dollars look what
number two is UK 8.7 France seven
Germany 6.46 Japan 4.36 trillion China
2.6 China is only in debt 2.6 Italy 2.5
Spain 2.26 Canada three to Australia
1.83 U.S 31 trillion dollars at 124 okay
so what's the big deal with this pal why
are we talking about this here's why you
know how we always trash Venezuela for
their high debt to GDP ratio right 350
percent my God look at Venezuela what
they're doing how much GDP they have
versus how much you know debt they have
or will make fun of greens because
they're at 206 percent as bad as Greece
isn't as terrible they are with their
finances we're at 124 it's not like
we're way behind him at 30 or 40
nobody's at 40 okay U.S is at 124 to 128
we are doing a horrible job so for
example and this is not a Democrat or
Republican both sides want to spend
money right now okay back in the days
Reagan used to say to Republicans Every
Day's Fourth of July to Democrats every
day is April 15th but today both of them
are spending money this is not a left or
right thing here's where I wouldn't be
concerned if we have 31.5 trillion hours
our GDP right now is roughly 25 trillion
dollars right if our debt is 31 and a
half but our GDP is 62 trillion okay
it's fine we're gonna be okay it's like
you're making 65 000 a year but you have
31 000 of debt okay today we're making a
hundred thousand dollars a year but we
have 128 000 in debt that's a lot of
money that's a real thing to be
concerned about we are the 12th highest
country in the world of debt to GDP
ratio this is not a good Leader's
bulletin to be on so my recommendation
which obviously I'm not in politics but
if I was looking at this and how this
relates to how we are as individuals and
companies whether it's a company whether
it's an individual or whether it's a
country pump the brakes on spending
let's figure out ways to increase GDP
and then let's try to keep this thing
flat and cut it down a little bit and
these interest rates can be scarier this
year with interest rates as it climbs
away it does and then if we increase
this and this is here then let's invest
they're all talking about right now
having to increase the debt limit so we
don't default obviously neither the left
or the right is going to allow us to
default that's a political catastrophic
event if they do that the market will
tank 33 percent to 40 if they do that
the world economy is going to take it no
one's going to allow America to get to
that point but
just like individuals just like
countries just like companies we have to
pump the brakes on spending and figure
out a way through Innovation to increase
GDP or else this debt payment this year
that could be a trillion to a trillion
and a half
is going to be a scary sight and the
brokest person when you make payments
are insane your debt's not going down
that's what America is going through
today so if you got value from this
video I want you to watch this next
video that I did on unemployment if
you've not seen this click here to watch
it it's a very very interesting data
take care everybody bye-bye bye
foreign
[Music]